Africa's big game unique and
spellbinding and every year tourists
from across the world pay many millions
of pounds to see it up close and
personal but a tiny fraction of those
visitors want more than just pictures
and memories of their safari they want
to kill to take an animal's life and
with it a trophy of the beast they've
slain and for that they're prepared to
pay huge amounts of money Minnesota
dentist Walter Palmer paid around thirty
five thousand pounds to hunt and kill
Zimbabwe most famous animal Cecil the
lion much needed revenue for a country
on its uppers but the man who had
studied a 12 year old male most of his
life says no amount of money can
compensate for losing such a pivotal
creature my personal feeling is lion
hunting shouldn't exist where I believe
hunting is is important lion hunting I
don't believe there's justification for
it anymore why not they too rare they're
too sensitive to to the off take of a
male a pride male the repercussions felt
after that hunt far exceed anything in
any other species Africa's wildlife is a
highly saleable commodity in all its
forms and hunting is too valuable to
many countries for it simply to stop its
reported trophy killing in southern
Africa brings in up to 1 billion dollars
a year conservationist trevor Lane was a
professional hunter for almost a decade
and says without the money it generates
most wildlife would be wiped out by
local farmers outside man
starving those kids on to school that
animal there is the white man locks it
it's freakin gone dude you better put a
value 2 and by putting a value 2 you see
that animal there you look after it and
then we will come and we'll hunt it if
you take the value away from that animal
he looks at it as a nuisance and
probably meat and they all get wrong in
Zimbabwe snatchin aparts hunting is
illegal but there are a few fences to
keep the animals on safe ground and
bordering the parks attracts of private
land well with the right paperwork
killing game is just business so this is
the GPS satellite collar that's exactly
what Cecil was wearing you've got a
battery unit at the bottom which
contains something of a hard drive and
then a satellite antenna on the top
Cecil and his pride brother Jericho were
both fitted with radio collars identical
to this one but Cecil was lured out of
the wangi national park to his death and
the latest tracking data from Jericho
shows he too strayed into dangerous
territory so 6 minutes past 2:00 he was
in the National Park six minutes past
4:00 many people here in the safari
business believe that conservation and
hunting are two sides of the same coin
and if you want to preserve beautiful
animals like this then every now and
again you have to accept the tens of
thousands of pounds a hunter will pay to
kill one of them in the African bush
life is red in tooth and claw it is
survival of the fittest and for the
people who live and make their living
here there is little room for
sentimentality about using hunting to
pay the bills in short if you're
prepared to cough up there isn't much
you can't track down kill and mount
however majestic their abode and Sky
News in Zimbabwe